you will never believe the song you chose for this wegovy ad
have you also trouble with your weight
same discover the power of Wegovy
with Wegovy I lost 35 pounds and some lost over 46 pounds
and I'm keeping weight off
they took this is me but instead of this is me
they said Wegovy
for context this is the music video
what I remember of this film
it was basically much people who were ostized from society
they became carnies because they weren't accepted literally anywhere else
people hated them and feared them because of their appearance
because it looks different than everyone else
right so this is a ballad about radical self acceptance
like they're like
I don't care if the world judges me
like this is who I am
I'm standing in myself like
I am comfortable and I'm happy with myself
this is who I am right
and the person who's singing the song
this is Bearded Fat Lady which
you know I was eating up because I love fat representation anyways
she's like this is me
I'm fat this is what I look like
you know owning herself
so for wegovy to use this song
this song in their weight loss drug ad
showing people who are like
talking about how they're finally happy because they're losing weight
it's like you are sick
I'm not even talking about wegovy itself
I'm just talking about the ad
that is so sinister
and evil
turning a self acceptance ballad into an ad for weight loss
and not even just using the song
but modifying it to go from this is me to Wegovy
you're sick you're so sick